nein nein kann ich nun schon alt ist ist
das eben so das eisenerz wollen
das ist in man hat mich richtig viel
eisen hatten wir aber irgendwann muss
was auch mal benutzten diese allgemein
bei autoreisen eisenerz ist auf die
mängel welche items hier schon von dir
habe ich ihm bös gegeben
jannik sienna ist ja klar
dank einer krankhaften was daran zum
lehrplan was machen was machst du denn
gerade sieben und guck mal nach draußen
sondern ich gerade mache ja die leute
sind rom ohne mops ganz viele monster an
bewässerungsanlage für unsere fehlern
alle sie habe alles getan ich hab den
schaufeln was komplett kaputt gemacht
durch die ganze sache okay sie wollen es
tut mir leid ich sowas wird nicht wieder
vorkommen
ich hoffe doch dass alle simon ich will
nichts sagen aber das sind zum direkt
neben die höhe
okay das war's trocken
du wusstest dass es kräfte sammelt dass
sie trotz mehr schocken das ist gut es
ist das ist logik lieber das ist logisch
dass noch eine frage zufällig da war
doch noch so coole sachen die ja die
youtube community
ja genau ja ich habe gerade einen abend
vergessen aber das haben viele leute
gefragt und wir brauchen einen extractor
bald also da will ich ganz zuerst was zu
sagen ja mach ich einfach mal bin meiner
meinung ist es gibt ja anstalt ist die
youtube community und jeder macht
sowieso sein ding und die das rivale und
so weiter okay es gibt einige leute mit
die meinen weg ich ja es gibt keine
community
das ist alles nur einzelpersonen die
nix für eine natur und somit das jetzt
wird ja also das hallt es gibt leute die
sagen halt zum beispiel jahres ist alles
so es ist also wieso realismus weil ihr
leid macht sein eigenes ding meiner
meinung ist ein kapitalismus jeder den
an sich selber und an seinen eigenen
nutzen der tasche wie heißt es noch mal
in wirtschaftslehre gibt es einen
bestimmten ausdruck der der homo
oeconomicus genau wie soja anständige
art homo oeconomicus ist eine person die
nur an seinen nutzen denkt das heißt
auch wenn er zum beispiel mal irgendwo
was spendet oder so nicht immer mit dem
hintergedanken dass es für ihn auch gut
ist das wirklich gerade zombie neben dir
weiß also dass da kann aber wie er das
gelernt wenn irgendjemand zb euch zehn
cent gibt aber dann sagt und dann denkt
ihr euch so hey der ist total nett ich
dachte dass wir von der geist aber dann
sagt er euch ja aber morgen 20 cent
wieder wegelin hat homo oeconomicus so
gut
und genau diese leute denken vielleicht
es gibt keine miete und alle das sind
sowieso feinde und ja man klaut sich die
opposition quatsch meiner meinung nach
ist es gibt schon community ein ganz
klares beispiel muss jetzt mal sagen ist
zum beispiel lud place lukas ist jemand
der wirklich meine augen nach so viel
politik auch kleine youtuber unterstützt
und zweifall als dre kraft oder so den
kann ein gläschen kommerzialrat place
obwohl er da schon halt viel mehr
abonnenten dazu aufgerufen harmonierten
und die gestützte kanals flächenzuwachs
und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen das ist
auf jeden fall ein beispiel dafür dass
es dann die zusammenhalt gibt die
community zusammenhalt und in der
hinsicht ist auf jeden fall solche luca
ist auch ein klares vorbild für mich in
richtung community und seitdem seitdem
ich das jetzt mitbekommen habt ihr seid
so läuft muss auch ganz geschützt auch
immer selber gerne kleinere youtuber und
tour auch selber halt sehr gerne was in
richtung community also ich bin der
meinung das ist so es ist wirklich ein
zusammenhalt gibt gerade in der politik
immer mal leute die sagen will ist nicht
so aber mein name ist schon so und es
ist ja auch so dass man sich einfach
untereinander vielleicht also ich selber
viele haben sich untereinander als
clever durch zum beispiel von mir
sprechen eigentlich alle mit den
schüssen habe sich aber wieder aufsuchen
an allem eine gruppe die box und das hat
man ja auch immer wenn man in welcher
handel games events macht oder einfach
nur zusammen
dass man sich wirklich alle haben sich
gegenseitig in skype das was sehr schön
finde ich eigentlich ja dass man
wirklich alle parat wenn man so denkt
gerne an hat man ihn wirklich auch zu
den kontakt und das hab ich auf jeden
fall die erfahrung macht sonst so ist
und ich bin auch sehr schnell sehr
herzlich aufgenommen worden
in dieser minecraft premiere nur das
weggehen
ich bin nämlich am sterben ja kann
machen was da kann ich nämlich wieder
weiter aus wir müssen uns wirklich
vernünftigen bett platz überlegen ich
würde sagen wir leben ein wo wir
wirklich wenn wir ein kind so über alles
drüber gucken können so ober von dach
oder so okay dachte bauen
mal gucken wer mehr zeit ich habe hunger
ich habe doch keine zeit
ich würd sagen ach ich hab ein
kartoffelfeld ich warte hier kartoffel
euch gerade zufällig ein kitzel gesehen
kannst du gucken welches also was ich
sagen wollte ich kann ein steak isst du
das ja okay gibt
ich brauche gar nichts zu essen also was
ich sagen wollte ich kann da ganz ganz
ganz ganz weit ausholen und zwar weil
mir die vorgeschichte dass ich damals
etwas mit youtube leuten gemacht habe
aber dann
ich sag mal ich enttäuscht wurde sondern
dann kam an einer aktion durch die ich
nicht die ich nicht sehr toll fand
einige wissen vielleicht was meine aber
möchte ich jetzt gar nicht darauf
einigen fans habe ich mir dann
geschworen dass ich nie wieder etwas mit
anderen leuten von youtube machen weil
ich einfach keinen bock nochmal in wiso
asoziale personen zu treffen sage ich
mal
hab dann allerdings jetzt eine community
gefunden die wirklich relativ nett ist
also mein weg wirklich zu einer anhörung
geladen aber nur relativ
sie ist nicht die community dich tun
habe also lässt sich ihr zuschauer
sondern die mit zb sich mit place und
pop und alle anderen oder dna oder spark
oder wenn er das camp ist da drin dieser
ganzen leute port of media und so ich
kann gar nicht aufhören jetzt alles
erzählen aber ich bin auf jeden fall
froh dass ich jetzt hier drin ist diese
bugs für popcorn und bin froh dass ich
in dieser kombi wurde das ganze als
ärztin man keine ahnung dass
rausgenommen wusste dass meine tasche
packen da rein
popcorn was passiert du ganz schnell und
ich packe der tür fest nein also was ich
noch sagen wollte ich wollte hatten
eigentlich geschworen nie wieder etwas
mit anderen youtuber zu machen weil ich
einfach keine lust darauf hatte aber
dann einerseits kommt man natürlich dran
vorbei wenn man jetzt in solche
community sachen machen will und oder
maps austesten will dazu und
andererseits bin ich auch relativ früh
zur zeit mit den leuten mit denen ich
etwas machen
da finde ich zurzeit wie sie jetzt zur
zeit ist sollte sich eigentlich auch nie
ändern finde ich und wenn er dann so
leute ankommen so depressiv meinen ja es
gibt gar keine community ist es nicht so
dass sie alle bauteile sich in skype
haben und quatschen
doch also bei mir und dann ist es so
oder
eigentlich also dass sich auch alles
gibt wahrscheinlich ausnahmen als es
wird wahrscheinlich leute die da
vielleicht nicht so viel wert auf den
mann los darauf haben oder sich da
einfach nicht so einbringen möchten kann
ja auch der er selbst entscheiden also
ich möchte jetzt auch niemanden irgendwo
persönlich angreifen wenn ich hatte
eigentlich respekt vor den personen die
meinen ja ich möchte eigentlich nichts
mit leuten von youtube so together
projekte starten das ist ja ein beispiel
ist ja wirklich nicht krank sondern
kommt hat ja schon mit den leuten was zu
tun aber doch dann keine videos mit
denen weil er wirklich findet ja alleine
finde ich doch eigentlich sogar
interessanter als in together projekte
aber das ist dass wirklich jeder selbst
entscheiden was er machen will das ist
halt das coole an youtube nur einfach zu
behaupten dass es keine community gibt
das leidige tun finde ich das schon arg
übertrieben vor allem das ist genauso
wenn man sagt so ja alle youtuber
allerletzt player haben kein leck
das ist auch wieder so allgemein gefasst
man muss jede person einzeln frank bei 7
und stimmt natürlich
ja ich habe zum glück nicht kalt und ja
also das zu dem thema ich hatte halt
wirklich mal so eine phase wo ich mir
gedacht haben ich habe keinen bock wenn
irgendwas mit leuten von youtube machen
nur mein eigenes ding
aber das war relativ kurz nur ich habe
ja vorher bevor ich jetzt in minecraft
kanal hatte hat sich ein lokal auf kanal
und und da habe ich wirklich selten das
sagen darf also ja auch schwer weil
damit ein schweres jahr ist einfach
schwierig aber mit meinen freunden aber
die waren kein youtube videos dann
gemacht aber ich habe keine ich hab mich
mit toren viel gemacht und das fand ich
eigentlich schade und deswegen habe ich
ja wirklich jetzt diesen gaming kanal
deswegen mag ich ja so einfach weil
ansonsten habe ich meine ja einfach mal
weil es einfach spaß hatte ein zucken
also meiner meinung nach gibt nichts
cooleres zusammen lasst einfach aus spaß
zu zocken dass dabei aufzunehmen und
dann noch beim brüten ja entspannt
ankommen dass das vielleicht ich immer
im alten wenn man wirklich dann den
leuten etwas bieten kann und wenn die
leute dann sagen ja das hat mir gefallen
oder das hat mir nicht gefallen dass wir
nicht immer maler coolsten also mehr
spaß als jetzt an letztes plain hatte
ich noch nie überhaupt an irgendwas also
es ist das größte was ich habe auch das
aller geld zur hobby weil einerseits
kann man das machen was ihm spaß macht
und zwar zocken man kann sich auslassen
der video bearbeitung etc was ich auch
später irgendwie so von beruf machen
möchte und man kann einfach sich
steigern sag ich mal kein kontakt mit
leuten haben man kann sich da steigern
kann
sie steigern in der qualität man hat
wirklich was ein ziel das man erreichen
kann
das war ein schönes wort ohne das wort
zum sonntag am montag er halte ich habe
auch nicht alle über diese scheiße hier
weg diese
die scheiße so einfach da bleiben ja
diese irgend ich habe hier nur noch in
kisten drin das sieht richtig leer jetzt
bei uns aus voll schön